jonathan we have a segment called um new
to drew it feels weird to say my name
but it rhymes and we love rhyming around
um and um i'm excited because i get to
learn new things um and we get to learn
something new together
i have actually i think i know i have
seen this on instagram but i've never
been so excited in my life i'm an avid
bake-off fan i'm not really a good baker
but i love bake off i love nailed it i'm
more on like the nailed it speed because
i can't really do it but i'm excited to
be here don't be scared don't you and
your husband like also love british bake
off
yeah um okay well we're gonna make a
tsunami cake and here to teach us how to
make a tsunami cake it's the owner and
ceo of make my cake in harlem new york
please
[Applause]
drew it's such a great
moment for me to be here with you you've
been a friend of my head since fire
starter
[Laughter]
and i love fire
jonathan awesome love you so much
we have
this
this trend that has taken over social
media yeah it has and the great thing
about it is that it's something that is
something you can do at home you don't
have to go to a bakery and get it done
you can do this at home
well we're what we've done and we've
made it a little bit easier for you
we've already done the cakes because we
want to do something very
cute with your face on it
so we're going to start with this we're
going to i want you to insert right in
the middle jonathan yes yours
and you're going to insert and then and
the finale is going to be
even more exciting so let's mix a little
okay just a little we're going to start
with just a little
come on
okay just a little bit just a little
like that yes we're going to start with
that much and then
spatulas everyone
stir and stir so what we have is a white
chocolate ganache that has been loosened
just a little bit with a little bit more
extra cream
so that way
so that way that the whole effect of it
flowing down because usually
i don't know how many home bakers are
here
any
awesome
i encourage that i was my mom's
apprentice when i was 12.
and we have grown our business just from
from our apartment all the way to three
store fronts right now oh my gosh
so and out of a coffee shop as well so
you have to come up and it's cold i like
it black
brilliant so this is a perfect color oh
good i feel good about this now the
cylinder so this cylinder is acetate
i'm gonna have you do it because i'm
giving y'all instructions
go straight down
all the way down and the key to the
cylinder
is that it's gonna be taped so you wanna
make sure that it is i wanna shove
you're gonna shove and don't worry about
this
don't worry about that's a good shove
that's a good shower no more okay oh my
god can i do it yes i want you to do it
okay
i want to push that down it sounds like
operation
you know what i mean it is
and then when you put the cylinder
okay what is drew doing oh she's going
around all the way down all the way down
okay all the way down okay okay now do
you feel like it's firm no what no i do
maybe
are you ready yes so this is the part oh
my gosh did we pour this in once in
there yes so we have to make sure this
is oh yeah because you don't want any oh
now i understand because i've done that
i've literally done that i have no it
got it it came apart and it just icing
tight
icing tight
yes so can i pour it in
do i get to pour it
i'm feeling i'm feeling good don't get
any on you oh god and don't get me on
you am i just pouring am i just going
rogue you're going to go around around
oh yeah don't get on the person
obviously yes
go around
okay
okay oh god okay keep going let me know
gosh keep going keep going
you got a great amount do we do it yes
so this is the fun part get your ghost
phones get your gold spoon okay
[Applause]
are we literally cake making
we are doing it jonathan so what
sprinkles would you like the great thing
about this is also the wow factor a
little bit better this cake concept is
all about the wow factor and it's all
about bios
so yeah are you allowed to do one of
everything what happens i think you i
want it all this is what i like so let's
have you met me let's go
there and let's go there oh shoot okay
but not the whole thing oh oh oh okay i
don't know because it's going to be too
much
if you do the whole thing i mean are you
having such anxiety right now watching
us do this i feel it i am human too
much i was like watching someone else do
highlights i'm like oh gosh i know
all right okay
now the
okay
[Music]
just like it's over this okay
cause we're ready yeah i want to be
ready yeah because this is
you all are not coming to the shop
without supervision okay mine's already
here we're ready
[Applause]
all right
take both ends like this
pull up now audience i want you to count
down
one
two
[Applause]
my little me wants to just like yeah
there we go i love it did we do this
i think i did great
[Applause]
thank you so much it's all about the wow
factor and that's exactly what you
delivered well wow thank you and a
little bit of a mess but it's okay well
messy and gorgeous messy gorgeous is our
theme yes
[Applause]
thank you so much for teaching us how to
make our very own fabulous tsunami cake
and jonathan again i love your book so
much
love that story it is available now
[Music]
you